Купити землю так само, як квартиру чи будинок. Або продати.
Або взяти кредит під заставу землі. Перетворити
свої гектари на родючі угіддя, а потім віддати
у спадок дітям. Або продати все утричі дорожче
й поїхати в навколосвітню подорож.
Майже в усіх державах cвіту це можливо.
Але не в Україні. Адже вже 17 років там діє
мораторій на продаж аграрної землі. Українців це,
на диво, не турбує, зокрема завдяки кільком
живучим міфам довкола цієї теми.
Земля вже належить українцям, які володіють
земельними паями. Сталося це ще в 1999-му році,
коли після ліквідації колгоспів і радгоспів
селяни отримали у власність колгоспну землю
паями, від двох до 20-ти гектарів на людину.
Тож на право власності скасування мораторію ніяк не вплине.
За оцінками проекту АгроІнвест, лише 15%
українських селян готові продавати свою землю
після скасування мораторію. Решта не поспішатиме,
адже ціни почнуть рости.
За оцінками Світового Банку, щонайменше утричі.
Відкритий ринок землі взагалі не означає, що
власник ділянки повинен її продати. Він лише
отримає право розпоряджатися своїми гектарами
відповідно до Конституції України.
Такий ризик існує, проте все в руках
української влади. Вона вже давно обіцяла
підготувати якісний закон про обіг землі, який
захистить інтереси селян та національну безпеку України.
Мораторій діє вже 17 років.
За цей час закон так і не з’явився.
Увесь цей час селяни мають право лише здавати
свої паї в оренду та передавати у спадок. Причому
роблять це практично за безцінь.
За офіційними даними, середня вартість оренди
1 гектару становить близько 1000 гривень на рік,
тоді як у Європі середня ціна оренди у 5 разів більша.
Вони можуть викупити частину землі, створити
нові робочі місця, запустити сучасне
високотехнологічне виробництво та платити
податки в бюджет України. Або мультинаціональні
корпорації намагатимуться скупити українські
чорноземи - і тут вже питання законодавства:
наскільки ретельно пропишуть закон,
чи пильнуватимуть правоохоронці та суди.
Український парламент може закрити іноземцям
доступ на ринок землі, а може обмежити продаж,
скажімо, трьома тисячами гектарів землі. Проте
іноземні компанії вже понад 10 років ведуть бізнес
в Україні: від Monsanto до Gargill, Du Pont та інших.
Понад 15 років в Україні успішно діє тіньовий ринок
землі, яка є джерелом корупції для всіх органів влади.
По-перше, мораторій стосується не лише
приватної землі, але й 10 мільйонів гектарів державної.
Виходить, що чиновники розпоряджаються землею
найбільшого землевласника - держави.
За даними Української аграрної конфедерації,
у 2017 близько 8 мільйонів га державної землі
оброблялося невідомо ким і поза межами правового поля.
По-друге, існують ще так звані незатребувані землі,
тобто гектари, власники яких померли або виїхали.
Цією землею опікуються місцеві громади, що теж є
джерелом корупції. Є питання й до того,
як власники паїв здають землю в оренду фермерам
або агрохолдингам. Часто це робиться або взагалі
без документів, або в угоді вказують занижену ціну.
Решту вартості селянин отримує готівкою,
а крім того додатково оформлює субсидію
як малозабезпечений.
До Жовтневої революції вже існувала
приватна власність за землю. Через те, що нині
земля орендована, фермери часто зовсім
не цінують її та навіть не намагаються
дотримуватися сівозміни й інвестувати у зрошення
або тваринництво, адже такі проекти окупляться
тільки через 10-15 років.
А от для власника земля – спадковий ресурс, який
годуватиме не одне покоління нащадків, якщо
про неї дбати. Тому в ідеалі відкритий ринок землі
має запровадити дбайливий підхід до неї.